Ron DeSantis is the governor of the
state of Florida we're delighted to have
him join us tonight Governor thanks so
much for coming in I have to say you're
one of the only politicians I've ever
seen at so many republican governors in
red States really are some of the
weakest people in the country have caved
you have not caved you've really tried
to explain what this bill is about if
you'll just do it quickly for us once
again what is this bill
well this bill is about providing
protection so that they know they can
send their young kids to school without
them being sexualized without a school
telling a young girl for example that
she may really be a boy and if schools
are trying to do things that impact the
health and well-being of the kids and
their their undertaking certain services
that parents have a right to know that
and provide consent for it so this is a
real bill that empowers parents it
protects our kids and for a company like
Disney to say that they this bill should
have never passed first of all Tucker
they weren't saying anything when this
was going through the house they only
started doing this because the mob the
woke mob came after him but put that
aside for them to say that them as a
california-based company are going to
work to take those California values and
overturn a law that was duly enacted and
as you said supported by a strong
majority of Floridians they don't run
this state they will never run this
state as long as I'm gov Governor yeah
they haven't improved Orlando I noticed
why don't they throw some money into
downtown Orlando and help the people who
live there I have to ask you this since
you're on the topic of Disney journalist
Chris Ruffo has really done a lot has
just obtained a video of an all hands
meeting at Disney the meeting was in
response to the legislation you signed
in Florida here is Disney corporate
president Carrie Burke watch this
I'm here as a mother of two queer
children actually
um uh one transgender child
um
and one pansexual child
um and and also as a leader many many
many
lgbtqia characters
in our stories and and and yet we don't
have enough leads
um and narratives in which gay
characters just just get to be
characters
um and and not have to be about
gay stories
so I don't understand why an
entertainment company that makes
animated movies gets to control
legislation in your state
one especially Tucker you got to wonder
like why is the hill to die on to have
transgenderism injected into
kindergarten classrooms or woke gender
ideology injected into second grade
classroom why is that the hill to die on
meanwhile if we had done a bill that
prohibited uh talking about the abuse of
uyghurs in China Disney would have
supported that legislation because they
don't want to say a word about that so
it's just an odd manifestation of their
corporate values that they actually do
Disney Cruises Tucker to the nation of
Dominica which criminalizes
homosexuality so they're fine doing that
and lining their pockets they're fine
lining their pockets from the CCP and
all the atrocities that go on there but
it's those kindergartners in Florida
that they really want to have
transgenderism as part of their Core
Curriculum in school and talking to kids
about their genitals like I I thought
that was I'm not a lawyer I thought that
would be a crime right no it should be
Tucker I mean I think about when I was
in school we just did school work uh you
know we did we did things like math and
science and reading I don't even know
how this would become fodder for for a
second grade classroom uh and so the
fact that they're going to this length
to try to torpedo legislation that I
think 90 of parents probably view is
just common sense
um it really makes you wonder you know
about what's motivating this decision
making it really does and just to be
clear final question I read the bill it
doesn't say anything about gay marriage
does it is it not an anti-gay marriage
bill Tucker Tucker the word gay is not
in the legislation right so they say
it's Banning a word that literally isn't
even in the legislation it's not even
like they're misrepresenting the way the
words use it's not even used in the bill
it's a it's a fake narrative it's a lie
but it's a lie because they have to lie
because if they admitted what they were
really for sexualizing kindergartners
and first graders they know that would
not fly with the public man you got a
lot of huevos to do this and I
appreciate it and I hope all all the
other cowards sitting in Governor's
offices around the country watch this
Rhonda Sanders thank you
thank you